♪ ♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HAPPY MONDAY, HAPPY
FRIDAY, HAPPY FRIDAY EVERYBODY.
I SAID MONDAY ALL THE DRINKING
IS STARTED.
FIRST LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
HE NOTES A THOUGHTFUL PROCESS
KINO EXTRA TOES.
NOVELIST AND LITERARY CRITIC
WALTER KIRN.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE IS SO SOUTHERN SHE SLEEPS IN
A DEEP FRYER.
COHOST OF THE BOTTOM LINE
LAUNCHES JANUARY 23RD.
DAGEN MCDOWELL.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE IS THE GIRL OF YOUR DREAMS
IF YOU HAVE A 104 FEVER.
[LAUGHS]
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
AND FINALLY, THE GREAT BARRIER
REEF IS HIS LOOFAH, MASSIVE SIDE
KICK IN THE WORLD HEAVYWEIGHT
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE GET TO SOME
NEW STORIES THAT ARE ALL THE
DOCUMENT SCANDAL IT'S TIME FOR
THIS.
♪ ♪
>> GREG'S LEFTOVERS.
>> Greg: I LOVE THIS.
WHERE I READ THE JOKE SO WE
DIDN'T USE THIS WEEK AND AS
ALWAYS IS MY FIRST TIME READING
THEM SO THAT THEY AREN'T FUNNY
DON'T BLAME ME I CHECKED OUT
MONTHS AGO.
HERE WE GO.
CONVICTED SEX TRAFFICKER IS
TEACHING ETIQUETTE CLASSES TO
FELLOW INMATES.
THAT IS NOT EVEN THE PUNCH LINE.
LESSONS INCLUDES TABLE MANNERS,
FORMAL GREETINGS AND FOLDED
BEDSHEETS WITH THE NECK.
ALSO AMONG OUR TOP RULES IT'S
NEVER POLITE TO ASK A TEENAGER
HOW OLD SHE IS.
[LAUGHTER]
MICROSOFT NEW AI TOOL ONLY NEEDS
TO HEAR THREE SECONDS OF HER
VOICE TO MIMIC YOU.
MAKING IT THE ONLY THING ON
EARTH THAT COULD DO IT FASTER
THAN YOUR ANGRY WIFE.
THAT IS THE STOCK PHOTO WE FOUND
TO EXPLAIN MARRIAGE.
STOCK PHOTOS ARE GREAT.
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND AMTRAK
TRAIN GOT STUCK IN
SOUTH CAROLINA AND TOOK OVER 36
HOURS TO GET TO FLORIDA.
USUALLY TO GET STRANDED THAT
LONG GIFT OF FLY SOUTHWEST.
AS NEW BOOK PRINCE HARRY SAID
THAT HE WANTS GOT FROSTBITE ON
HIS, ON A TRIP TO THE
NORTH POLE.
LUCKILY HIS BALLS WERE SAFE IN A
JAR IN HIS WIFE'S PURSE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
YEAH.
AIDS PRESIDENT BIDEN DISCOVERED
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN HIS
POSSESSION.
HE HAS SINCE APOLOGIZED SAYING
THAT HE SAW THE WORDS TOP-SECRET
AND THOUGHT IT WAS THE KFC
RECIPE.
PROFESSOR AT PENN STATE
UNIVERSITY IS COMING THAT
STRAIGHT PEOPLE CAN LEARN TO BE
BISEXUAL SIMPLY BY WATCHING.
I REMADE SCOTT AND I ALREADY
KNEW THAT.
I SHOULD READ THESE.
IN MASSACHUSETTS THIS WEEK
BEN AFFLECK WAS SPOTTED SERVING
PEOPLE AT A DUNKIN' DONUTS
DRIVE-THROUGH SAID IT'S ALWAYS
NICE TO DISAPPOINT CUSTOMERS
WITH SOMETHING BESIDES MY
ACTING.
SIX JOURNALISTS IN SOUTH SUDAN
WHERE REST OF THIS WEEK OVER THE
CIRCULATION OF FOOTAGE APPEARING
TO SHOW THE PRESIDENT WETTING
HIS PANTS.
THERE WERE LATER RELEASED AND
SAID THEY COULD KEEP QUIET ABOUT
OUR PRESIDENT THEY WILL HAVE A
JOB AT CNN.
[APPLAUSE]
YES, IT'S A SMATTERING.
VETERAN TOOK DOWN EIGHT KNIFE
WIELDING MAN AT ALL LAST
WEDNESDAY NO SHOPPERS WERE
STABBED OVER THE SEVERAL DID DIE
FROM OBESITY.
THAT SEEMED KIND OF LOW.
AND OUT OF LEFT FIELD.
AND FUNNY.
FATHER IN ECUADOR HAS LEGALLY
CHANGED HIS GENDER TO IMPROVE
HIS CHANCES IN A CUSTODY CASE.
IF HE WINS HE PROMISES TO SUE
HIMSELF FOR CHILD SUPPORT.
AND FINALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HIS PRESIDENCY JOE BIDEN
VISITED THE BORDER IN EL PASO
THIS WEEK.
WHEN ASKED WITH THE MOST
MEMORABLE PART ABOUT THE TRIP
WAS?
WHILE OBVIOUSLY WAS WHEN I SAID
TEAR DOWN THIS WALL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO SOME NEWS.
[LAUGHS]
HE LEFT FILES BY THE CORVETTE
AND LIKE HIS PANTS THE EXCUSES
ARE ALL WET.
SPECIAL COUNSEL ON THEY ARE HAS
BEEN APPOINTED TO INVESTIGATE
HOW TOP-SECRET CONSULATE
DOCUMENTS ENDED UP IN
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S DELAWARE
GARAGE AND AN OFFICE USED IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., IT'S TRUE YOU
CANNOT FIND CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WHEREVER BALANCE OF NATURE IS
SOLD.
I'M TRYING TO A SPONSOR DEAL.
SHOCKING USUALLY WHEN HE LEAVES
ME BEHIND ITS FOLLOWED UP WITH A
CARPET STEAMER.
A LOT OF JOKES.
IT COULD BE AN HONEST MISTAKE
AFTER ALL HE LEFT BEHIND A LOT
MORE IN AFGHANISTAN LIKE WEAPONS
AND PEOPLE.
BUT ACCORDING TO ONE DEMOCRAT
CONGRESSMAN FROM GEORGIA
SOMETHING MUCH MORE NEFARIOUS IS
AFOOT.
>> I'M SUSPICIOUS OF THE TIMING
OF IT.
I'M ALSO AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
THINGS CAN BE PLANTED ON PEOPLE
THINGS CAN BE PLANTED IN PLACES
AND THEY DISCOVERED
CONVENIENTLY.
>> Greg: THAT'S AN INTERESTING
THEORY ALMOST AS INTERESTING AS
GUAM TOOK BEING OVER INTO THE
OCEAN.
>> MY FEAR IS THAT THE WHOLE I
ISLAND WILL BE SO OVERLY
POPULATED THAT IT WILL TIP OVER
AND CAPSIZE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: IT'S A CLASSIC AND I
LOVE THAT MAN.
SO IS ACTUALLY SUGGESTING THAT
SOMEONE PLANTED THE DOCUMENTS TO
FRIEND THE PRESIDENT.
IT SEEMS PRETTY HARD TO BELIEVE
CONSIDERING THE GARAGE WAS
LOCKED.
LET'S BE HONEST IF HE'S BEEN
FRAMED WE KNOW WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITY.
[LAUGHS]
>> WHAT YOU WANT TO KNOW?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: DO YOU KNOW WHO THE
REAL WINNERS ARE IN ALL DISK
WHICH MARKED CHINESE SPIES.
WHO CANNOT GET TOP-SECRET FILES
IN GARAGE SAILS BEFORE.
[LAUGHTER]
WALTER, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR YOUR
OPINIONS I LOVE THE STORY IS THE
BEST STORY IS THE BEST KARMIC
STORY OF THE YEAR.
FOR THIS EARLIER DON'T YOU
THINK?
>> Walter: I THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SAID IT'S TIME
TO LOCK JOE BIDEN IN THE GARAGE.
IT'S PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA YOU
SELECT LIKE A VINTAGE CORVETTE
JOE BIDEN.
HE'S KIND OF NOSTALGIC TO LOOK
AT BUT IF YOU TAKE IT OUT AND
DRIVE IT IN MY BREAKDOWN AND YOU
CAN'T GET PARTS.
[LAUGHS]
IS ALSO LIKE A VINTAGE CORVETTE
AND THAT HE DOESN'T MEET MODERN
EMISSION STANDARDS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
NO CATALYTIC CONVERTER THAT
OBNOXIOUS TAILPIPE EMISSIONS.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO TRUE.
>> Walter: WHY ARE THERE
DOCUMENTS IN THE GARAGE?
IT'S IN EVERY THING ON A
COMPUTER THESE DAYS?
I'M THE ONLY DOCUMENTS LEFT OUR
MARRIAGE LICENSES, THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE SO
WHAT IS IN THEIR?
LIKE THE MAGNA CARTA?
TO USE A BIT OF YOUR METAPHOR IF
THIS IS A PLOT BY THE DEMOCRATS
WHICH IT MIGHT BE TO GET AMOUNT
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
THE CAR KEYS FROM GRAMPS.
THAT'S WHAT THE TRYING TO DO.
>> Kat: OR COULD BE BECAUSE
THEY WANT DONALD TRUMP TO LOOK
GOOD BECAUSE I THINK THAT
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE EASIER TO
BEAT THAT SOME YOU LIKE
RON DeSANTIS.
I'M SAYING FOR BEING
CONSPIRACIES GET MORE CREATIVE.
SUE ON THAT IS A GOOD ONE THAT
IS A LOT OF WORK THOUGH.
LAST SUNDAY DID THAT.
>> Tyrus: THEY TRY THAT BEFORE
AND HE GOT ELECTED.
>> Kat: THEY DID THEY
ABSOLUTELY DID THAT ALREADY BUT
THIS DEAL SO COMFORTABLE RUNNING
AGAINST HIM DON'T HAVE MUCH
ELSE.
THEY'RE STILL DOING THE YEAH
LOOK UP TRUMPETS THING.
THEY'RE STILL DOING THAT.
THIS IS LIKE A KARMIC IMPLOSION
OF THE SCALE.
RIGHT?
YOUR MIND SAY THAT BECAUSE BOTH
SELF-RIGHTEOUS BLOWHARDS BUT A
SPECIFIC THING.
RIGHT?
IN THAT SPECIFIC THING HAS PUT
THEM ON THEIR OWN UNEVEN KNOW
WHAT THAT IS.
BUT I LIKE TO BE HOISTED ON ONE
OF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> Dagen: I BET YOU WOULD.
>> Greg: HOIST ME I SAY.
>> Dagen: I DO HAVE A LOT OF
ROPES AND PULLEYS AT HOME.
I WON'T SAY THAT WORD BECAUSE OF
A DO IN SOUTHERN IT'S GONNA GET
ME INTO TROUBLE.
I'M NOT CANNOT TALK ABOUT THAT
BUT I DO UNDERSTAND PEOPLE,
WOMEN WHO CARRY GRUDGES AS I
HAVE A LOT OF LITTLE HOMEMADE
DOLLS MY APARTMENT PEOPLE I PUT
HEXES ON OLD PANTY HOSE STUFF
WITH COTTON BALLS.
NEVER MIND.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A WOMAN I'M
GONNA TRAVEL DOWN TYRESE'S ROAD,
BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TO GET BACK
IN A MAN YOU GO AFTER HIS CAR.
YOU GO ON THE GARAGE WITH THE
STILETTO YOU GOT FOR THE TIRES
ON THE VET AND WHILE YOU'RE IN
THE GARAGE SHAVING THE TIRES
DURING A PLANT SEMESTER
DOCUMENTS TO MAKE SURE THE
THINK TANK DOCUMENTS IN D.C. ARE
NOT A ONE-OFF.
INTERESTING THAT A BOX IS
DEFTLY, HARRIS.
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE IF YOU
LISTEN TO HER WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR CALIFORNIA I
WAS A U.S. SENATOR IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS YOU HAVE ME TALK ABOUT
SPACE WITH SOME KID ACTORS AND
BEING A GREETER FOR DEAD FISH IN
THE PHILIPPINES.
AND NOW YOU'VE DECIDED YOU OLD,
THAT YOU'RE RUNNING AGAIN.
YOU HAVE TO GET RID OF THEM.
>> Kat: GET THE GET WITH HIS
DAD AND THEN YOU MAKE HIM CALL
YOU HIS STEPMOM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THAT IS INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT TYRUS
THAT --
>> Tyrus: HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: I WAS LIKE SHOULD I
SAY IT?
AND THAT IT WAS TOO LATE.
THAT WOULD HURT RIGHT?
>> Tyrus: I CAN'T SAY IT.
>> Greg: HE WAS THE GUY.
>> Tyrus: SHE PUT THEM ON A
BUS.
BUT SHE LOVES BUSES.
SO IT'S CONFUSING.
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
HE PUT ME ON THE BUS SOMATA PUT
HIM ON THE BUS OUT OF D.C.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Tyrus: SHE COULDN'T SAY
THAT BECAUSE THAT SOUNDED COOL.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THIS WHOLE
THING IS THAT THEY STILL BLAME
ALL THIS ON THE DONALD TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BECAUSE THEY MADE IT WEIRD WHEN
THE TRANSITIONING AND THAT'S ALL
IT TOOK ALL OF DOCUMENTS WITH US
BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY GIVE IT TO
THAT SOLELY WITH THEY'RE GOING
WITH WHICH MAKE ZERO SENSE.
THIS IN, THE PEOPLES PROBABLY
JUMP ON THIS BUT THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU LET YOUR KIDS
PUT YOUR STUFF AWAY.
THEY JUST PUT ANYWHERE.
HUNTER HAD ONE JOB TO DO.
ONE THING, TAKE ALL THE
DOCUMENTS THAT CONNECT ME TO YOU
AND GET RID OF THEM.
AND HE HAD THEM AT THE PLACES
WHERE HE WOULD NEVER GO, A
LIBRARY, DADS GARAGE, AND HOME.
CLASSIC SON [BLEEP] UP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
HE HAD ONE JOB.
>> Greg: LAST WORD TO YOU.
HAS A BEEN A GREAT WEEK PRONTO,
JUSTICE?
>> Kat: SOMETHING'S GONNA
HAPPEN WHEN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THEY ARE AFFORDED SPECIAL
TREA